we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here is an individual who called in
very very confused about my family
background listen to this
hi david so i can't help but notice that
you're jewish and from argentina that's
true so far beautiful
do you have a family history
that
has ties to germany
no like did you are you from argentina
because your family escaped the
holocaust and uh fled to argentina along
with a lot of other people who did that
well yes to some degree not from germany
uh
on my
basically three of my four grandparents
had families that went to argentina
well before world war ii
one grandparent went to argentina from
poland very very close to world war ii
but nothing germany related uh from
germany and if so
um did is that part of your motivation
for doing the shows to fight back
against fascism and nazi ideology that
the trump administration is bringing
back to the mainstream well i mean
listen
yes
part of the reason for doing this show
is to fight against right-wing
authoritarianism
uh fascism etc but because i think those
things are bad
not because my family is from germany so
certainly some elements in that
voicemail that are mildly tethered to
reality but the big picture
not not quite so much but i still
appreciate the opportunity to clarify
folks the member town hall is tomorrow
night 6 p.m eastern wednesday august
31st member town hall okay oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad yes when you become a
member at joinpacman.com
you get access to the bonus show
and you also get invited to participate
in the members only town halls it will
be streaming live for everybody on
youtube twitch and facebook tomorrow at
6 pm eastern but the participants will
be limited to our website members you
can become a member in mere moments by
signing up at joinpackman.com we've got
a great bonus show for you today
buoyed by a number of different
legislative accomplishments and a rising
approval rating
joe biden is going to give a prime time
speech to the nation
about the soul of the united states on
thursday evening in philadelphia i will
be covering it live in prime time we
will talk about that speech and the
timing on the bonus show we will also
talk about the launch of nasa's giant
moon rocket which has sadly been delayed
after an engine issue i was looking
forward to this we will talk about it on
the bonus show and pennsylvania
democratic senate candidate john
fetterman is calling on joe biden to
move towards decriminalizing marijuana
ahead of biden's visit to pennsylvania
on thursday which i agree with we will
talk about all of those things and more
when i am joined by producer pat on
today's bonus show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpacman.com
otherwise we'll be back tomorrow with a
brand new show